My father grew up in the Deep South
in the 1940s and '50s,
at a time when schools
were still segregated
and the promise of going to college
was less a promise
and more like a game of roulette.
And so for many like him,
the only real choices they had
were to stay in their hometown,
go into the military
or to attempt to go to college.
Well, my father served 20 years,
proudly and honorably,
in the United States Air Force.
The barriers to college
were just too high.
When he retired from the military,
he did go back to college,
and using his GI Bill
and studying at night
for almost six years,
he graduated one year before
I was graduating from college.
I remember going to his commencement
and watching him walk across the stage,
and my eyes just filled with tears.
And I actually am not sure
that I saw him get his diploma,
because I was crying like a baby.
(Laughter)
You know, around the world,
less than seven percent of people
own a bachelor’s degree.
But there are many
who would like to go to university.
But for them, much like my father,
the barriers to getting into
and graduating from college
are just too high.
It simply costs too much.
And that cost is often
the price of tuition.
In the United States,
a four-year bachelor's degree
can cost in excess of 100,000 dollars,
and that price point
continues to escalate.
And this is true
in other parts of the world,
but sometimes, the cost is high
because there is no university nearby
to study, on- or off-line.
Or because the academic
hurdles are so high
that university is only afforded
to the privileged few.
We, as institutions of higher education,
we build walls around ourselves
and expect students
to find their ways over.
But this shouldn't be.
What I care most about,
and what I have devoted
my entire career to as an educator,
and now, as an administrator
at one of the largest universities
in the United States,
is seeing more people --
traditional college-aged
as well as working adults --
getting into and graduating from college.
But if we are to do this,
institutions are going
to have to redesign themselves
to reach out and reach for more students,
versus students
trying to reach the institutions
over those walls.
And if we are going to do that,
we have to dramatically drive down
the cost of higher education,
and the way to do it
is to rethink and reimagine
in these three ways.
We have to rethink time ...
place ...
and how we teach.
So the first is time.
Time goes hand in hand with cost,
and this is how it typically goes.
College courses and degrees
are typically assessed
based on credit hours.
And each credit costs money.
So therefore, in this scenario,
time, therefore cost,
is fixed,
and learning is variable.
This really makes it problematic
to drive down cost,
and it particularly becomes problematic
if you’re trying to balance school,
work and other family obligations,
as well as other obligations
and responsibilities.
But if we are to flip that scenario,
and therefore make learning the constant
and time variable,
then we break the tyranny of time.
I mean, really, isn't that
what school is about?
It's about learning and gaining mastery,
versus logging in
a particular number of hours.
So what could we do?
We should make and give academic credit
for life experiences.
Why sit through an entire
business management course
for a semester,
when you can have
a university evaluator assess you
based on your experience?
So this is what this would look like.
Let's take a student, Brandice.
Brandice is an automotive technician
at a car service center.
Now let’s take three
of the certifications that she received
and is required for her to do her work:
electrical systems;
manual drive, train and axles;
and engine performance.
Now you take those
and you couple with the fact that Brandice
is actually managing a team of technicians
on the floor.
You assess all of that,
and she finds out that she's just
a few credits shy of a college degree,
a degree in automotive engineering
or engineering management.
And then on top of that,
during that assessment,
she find out that she has a pathway
to receive the remainder of those credits
for her degree
in less than five months.
A few of us are doing this.
But here's what I hope for.
My hope is that time
becomes even more variable.
So let's build a global skills bank,
much like a financial bank.
But in this case,
skills and experiences are the currency.
So if you take an evening
course in accounting,
deposit that into your bank.
If you do a summer internship
at a marketing firm,
deposit that into your bank.
If we're able to do this,
and do this at scale,
we could dramatically decrease
the time to complete a degree,
therefore drive down cost.
Second ...
place.
We have to completely reenvision
and reimagine how we think [about]
and we see place.
We know that physical college campuses
are expensive to maintain,
and we have to understand
that we should look at learning options
in a variety of different ways.
But there's also another cost
that we need to lower ...
and it's the cost of belonging --
whether it's because there is not
a university nearby for you to learn,
be it online or offline,
or because there are
emotional or cultural walls
that disconnect the learner
from that learning location.
Cameron, as a student,
should be able to take classes
in a community center
or in his church.
He should be able to seek
career advising and support
from local business owners and businesses.
We should be able to take his work
and his volunteer experiences
and turn those intro credits,
all in a community that he trusts.
And then therefore,
we are making that community
a thriving, vital part
of a learning ecosystem,
for him and for many others.
If we can do this,
this means that we absolutely
have to believe
that learning can take place anywhere.
And if we do,
then we decrease the cost of place.
Finally,
teaching, what about teaching?
Well, teaching
is at the heart of learning.
Teaching is the inspiration
and the connection.
It is the spark that connects
the learner to the information.
So there's nothing that we want to do
to mess with that magic.
But we do know that teaching
is one of the higher costs of education.
So what do we do?
We should take the most inspirational
and engaging teachers,
and all that teaching charm
that comes with it,
and make bigger classrooms for them,
scaling and expanding their reach.
So most classes are 20 to 30 students,
or in some cases, a couple of hundred.
But in online,
you can reach thousands
all around the world.
We currently have a course called
Human Relations and Administration.
It's a foundational course
for all undergraduate business majors.
This course has upwards of 3,000 students
from all over the world --
the US, Canada, Germany, India
and the list just goes on and on.
We also have classes
that are upwards of 5,000,
and we aspire to scale even more.
We want it so that wherever you have
an internet connection,
you can put a virtual butt in a seat.
Now,
there are folks
who are skeptical about online,
particularly large online classrooms,
and they posit that smaller
classrooms are better.
But I would argue what smaller classrooms
are really providing is personalization.
As so with personalization,
this is what I want to see.
I want to see a student,
regardless of where they are,
regardless of their location,
have a single source,
be it their mobile phone or their laptop,
where they have access to instruction,
in real time or in their time.
I want a faculty member
to be able to anticipate
a particular need for a student,
outreach to that student,
provide a connection for that student
with a prepackaged academic toolkit
that was prepared by a virtual
or automated resource or service,
and provide that human intervention
for that student just at the right time.
That's what chatbots
and predictive analytics and AI
can provide a university:
insights into when is it the right time
to provide that human intervention
that helps that student to become unstuck,
and to provide that personal support
the student may need.
Some of us are doing this.
But if we can really do this,
and do this at scale,
we are solving the problem
by building faculty
to do the thing that they are best at,
and to do that inspiration at scale.
And at the same time,
we are helping to drive down
the cost of higher education
by still providing the personal support
at the time that it's needed.
So I began this talk
talking about my father.
There's a lot that has changed
about higher education
over this period of time,
and there are things
that have not changed.
We, as institutions,
still find ourselves
being exclusive and expensive,
keeping students
on the wrong side of that wall.
Instead of thousands
of autonomous universities,
this is what I would like to see happen.
I would like to see universities,
companies and governments
invest deeply in a higher
education superhighway
that allows for the fluidity
and the transferability of experiences
from place to place,
from workplace to the classroom ...
beyond borders and beyond boundaries.
And in this case ...
skills and competencies
become the currency
for a global workforce.
And if we're able to do this ...
I invite you to a graduation
where we will have seen millions,
and possibly billions of students
walk across that stage.
Thank you.
(Cheers and applause)